У районі Ауреліо в Римі родина Бароне
відтворила шматочок Сицилії:
їхні каннолі з рикоттою
та кассаттина з марципаном - популярні серед римлян.
Син опікується баром, батько Доменіко орудує на кухні:
готує для працівників сусідніх офісів
ризото з морепродуктами та рибу-меч –
звичайно, з сицилійської батьківщини!
Сицилія - багатий край: риба, сільське господарство,
відмінний клімат, чудове море!
9 років тому родина змушена була залишити Сицилію.
На бідному півдні Бароне не вдавалося знайти працю
з достойним заробітком, якого вистачало б для безбідного існування.
Усі свої заощадження вони зрештою вклали у Римі у цей бар.
Розаріо розуміє, чому багато італійців нині роблять ставку на популістів,
які обіцяють новий старт.
Італія повинна знову стати суверенною країною.
Ми не вирішуємо за себе. Всі економічні рішення
в останні 20 років нам диктувала Європа,
тому що Європа чогось хоче, тому що Європа чогось потребує.
І ніколи не йшлося про те, що італійці чогось хочуть.
Батько і син вірять, що новий уряд популістів
"Руху п'яти зірок" та ультраправих "Ліги Півночі"
зможуть повернути Італії гордість за своє походження,
зокрема, і в їхній рідній Сицилії.
Місто Рагуза-Ібла приваблює численних туристів,
проте безробіття тут все одно високе.
У місцевій адміністрації вже п'ять років засідають представники "Руху п'яти зірок".
Після зміни уряду в Римі на часі вибори нового мера.
Агітувати з Риму особисто приїздить…
…Луїджі Ді Майо - лідер "Руху п'яти зірок"
і щойно призначений міністр праці.
Він рекламує свій уряд і свого кандидата на посаду мера в Рагузі.
І знову багато обіцяє!
З добрим міністром фінансів, з гарним головою уряду
ми доб'ємося за переговорним столом в Європі,
щоб до нас ставилися так, як і до інших європейських країн.
Популісти успішно розпалюють злість на Європу.
Якщо ми спільнота, тоді у всіх мають бути однакові права і обов'язки.
Не може так бути, щоб Європою керувала Німеччина.
Є також країни і на півдні.
Мер Федеріко Піччітто відчуває підтримку.
Його "П'ять зірок" тепер при владі у Римі.
Він сподівається на щедру фінансову підтримку
і на вирішення усіх проблем його міста.
Занадто мало фінансових ресурсів , забагато бюрократії,
відсутність нових робочих місць –
цьому покладемо край! Наш новий уряд про це подбає!
Мер переконаний, у сицилійців є ще одна причина сердитися на Європу.
На заповнені нині відпочивальниками пляжі в останні роки
висадилися сотні тисяч біженців та мігрантів.
Багато хто вважає, що Європа залишила
Сицилію напризволяще з цією проблемою.
Мовляв, Рагуза змінилася:
тепер тут живуть багато вихідців з Африки,
які не отримали притулку, але яких водночас
не можна депортувати  до рідних країн  - це великий тягар для міста.
Тож настрої в Італії стають дедалі більш націоналістичними,
нарікає кандидат на посаду мера від демократичної партії.
Такі партії, як його,
не мають рецептів проти популістів.
Я дуже занепокоєний. Альянс "Руху п'яти зірок" і "Ліги Півночі"
є популістським і ультраправим.
Це антиєвропейський союз, який ризикує подальшим
перебуванням Італії в Єврозоні,
а відповідно – і заощадженнями італійців.
Розаріо Бароне у Римі дивиться на це зовсім по-іншому.
Він інвестував,  тричі на тиждень додатково пропонує вечерю,
аби збільшити оборот.
І так, на його думку, зараз має бути по всій Італії.
Інвестувати, а не заощаджувати. От у чому рішення!
Великий виклик полягає у відновленні економічного зростання півдня країни.
Нині він - як дитина, яка лише стає на ноги.
Однак сильна держава може забезпечити, щоб Сицилія,
увесь південь, Італія знову розквітли.
І Європа також за це відповідальна,
переконані батько і син.